all right friends at home tonight your
top 10 are trying to win you over again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
are you okay
katy perry was a fish out of water
during sunday's live episode of american
idol and fell right out of her chair
katie in normal clothing is a lot to
deal with but mermaids are
you know they're challenging it was
somewhere between i love lucy and i
don't know what that was slapstick it
was so much fun tonight the 37 year old
singer dressed up as ariel from the
little mermaid to celebrate idol's
annual disney night you know what they
say flipping your fins you don't get too
far so katie
she straight up hit the floor near the
top of the show all right friends at
home tonight your top 10 are trying to
win you over again
[Applause]
[Laughter]
are you okay
cameras didn't actually catch the moment
katie hit the floor but we could hear it
again
and her fellow judges luke bryan and
lionel richie as well as host ryan
seacrest were there in a nanosecond to
lend a hand are you all right
she's all right she's all right
okay
[Applause]
get it there you go
phil take it from here
[Music]
mermaids and chairs you know they don't
they don't mesh well e.t chatted with
luke after the big show where he dished
on the singer's costume we were thinking
about toading her
but
there was all these oils that she i
guess had to to coat down in like crisco
or something so she was slippery and
then uh but then last minute i was like
let's just dolly her out but uh i mean
we knew that
all of that would create some some fun
stuff and obviously it did all right
friends at home tonight your top 10 are
trying to win you over again
[Applause]
and he wasn't kidding not only was katie
rolled out to the stage she had the
mermaid thing but she couldn't walk
what do you think so they said can you
carry her out well she's oiled up she
was rolled across the red carpet too you
roll out in a costume that you clearly
don't have your land legs tell me about
no i don't have those things that people
call feet so
um yes i had to come out in a dolly and
luke was helping me and lionel was
holding my fin and i was a little
slippery they didn't really like it was
getting all over their
really expensive clothes she's so
slippery it literally was like a fish
slime like actually
fish slime it was super fun and then um
i had a little bit of a tumble
[Laughter]
katie shared a little behind-the-scenes
clip slipping into that mermaid tail on
instagram almost push
push and she had a good laugh over her
tumble too
sharing the hilarious moment and joking
in the caption quote swipe to see what
almost accidentally killed lionel richie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
human chair what were they thinking i'm
used to just being on rocks but even
with her fall on stage we know katie's
getting cool mom points with her
one-year-old daughter daisy she has no
idea i'm in this right now and she just
started watching little mermaid actually
face timer before bedtime what time is
it tell her not to put her to bed just
yet she won't even believe it that her
mom is ariel
[Music]